PE turn around get a stop get a stop I
got
ball stay low stay low congratulations I
appreciate that on
everything I'm making shots that's my
Swagger you feel me I got to get back to
the basics first I got to stick the land
and like go back to the fundamentals of
Basics shot stay there till the ball go
in you know what I mean good job fell
good job big fella hey D that last one
though scream cuz you ain't really
scream now he fake coralin now y don't
got to be up if you screen now he can
turn now it's going to be more space
Double J Double J in the pocket Double J
he going to be up you in the pocket y
one quarter bro one quarter one quarter
let's
[Music]
go there you go P come on come on tell
them be patient tell them relax yeah t
good job Russ job p p good job broy